[Music]
this morning on the dish
from food styling and photography to the
opening of a celebrated restaurant
the dynamic duo you're about to meet can
do it all write about food take pictures
of it
and cook it in pretty amazing ways they
are the team behind
canal house the famed cookbook brand
that just branched out
if you like looking at great food or
better yet eating it
meet hersheimer and hamilton
90 minutes west of new york city in the
small town of milford new jersey
nestled near the pennsylvania border and
the delaware river
there's an old train station that's been
turned into something new
a world-class dining destination our
favorite fried chicken is stuck
the romance of a train station in a
little
river town with the bridge right there
and the river flowing by
and it was really all here we just
edited a few things photographer
christopher hersheimer
and food stylist melissa hamilton have
been editing and cooking together for
more than three decades
a creative partnership that has
transformed how we look at food
over the years hersheimer and hamilton's
work has graced the pages of books by
julia child
lydia vastianich and alice waters among
many others
first it was sever magazine which
emphasized natural light over fussy food
placement
then in 2009 the team launched canal
house cookbooks
a seasonal publication full of personal
travel logs and original recipes
that became a hit there was a feel that
we were after
we're really looking for emotional
connection i mean it's apparent
they're gorgeous and we didn't even want
them to be gorgeous actually
we wanted them to be because we didn't
want them to be precious
and we didn't want people to sort of
hang on i mean we wanted them so
ephemeral
that that once the season was finished
next season comes you know toss in and
the next book would come
each edition of canal house explores a
new theme from la dolce vita and italian
cooking
to farmers markets and gardens in 2013
they won the james beard award for canal
house cooks every day
a compilation of recipes for home cooks
by home cooks
we don't like to think of ourselves as
chefs we say we're cooks
you know chefs really run kitchens and
we have to run our kitchen but
our food is more recognizable we're
looking for someone
to recognize something when they eat it
and you think of chefs today they're
often trying to surprise you
the way that we cook we feel like it
takes it back to sort of a classic
place and flavor
now with their first restaurants canal
house station
the feature for hersheimer and hamilton
has been on long
sunday dinners a five course meal that's
meant to be
a bit of a throwback when we opened here
we sort of revived
a tradition that used to be a tradition
all across this country and of course in
europe
everywhere the sunday dinner families
got together
aunts and uncles it's how you found out
what was going on with everyone
hersheimer and hamilton showed us how
they bring it together
okay let's see what's living in here
including this
giant mushroom oh that's so gorgeous
that was awesome aren't those amazing
that's uh mayataki have you ever had
those
that looks so good the mushroom hamilton
carved was set to be served
with duck legs and this borscht pureed
and prepared with horseradish
sour cream dill and chives by the time
they were done
we had a feast that was both a culinary
and visual delight
what's your favorite right now right at
this moment
duck legs with mayataki mushrooms
chipolini and polenta i mean where are
you going to get that
here yeah
it looks tremendous also on the table
warm spice pecans deviled eggs with mayo
dijon mustard sour cream smoked salmon
and chives
a green salad and that borscht i don't
think i've ever seen a dish with better
color than that borscht
the beets did all the work there was
also apple almond cake for desserts
and a cocktail of gardeners gin and
lemon cheers
cheers for the time being hersheimer and
hamilton have not been able to serve all
this regularly
inside the restaurant but they are still
doing their version of
sunday dinner in takeout form so people
who still crave the classics
can enjoy at home it's still having a
kind of a communal experience and we'll
get back to the way it was
hopefully we'll throw away the bad parts
and keep the good things that we learned
and
slow it down it's a gorgeous setting
it's incredible food and they're just
wonderful
to spend time with and they're right in
my own backyard
yeah not too far from you
yeah i gotta tell you that that borscht
was one of the best things i've ever had
wow looked beautiful